-Welcome back, everybody.
I'm here with Tariq Trotter
from the Roots right there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We're about to play a game
called Flip Shots.
Here we go.
-♪ Flip shots, shots,
shots, shots ♪
♪ Flip shots ♪
-And seeing as both
of our guests are here
to promote their own drinks,
I thought this game
was a perfect fit.
First up, her Prosecco line
Viarae is available now.
Please welcome Issa Rae.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You ready?
-I'm so ready.
-Are you ready for this?
Ready for this?
And she is the creative director
of martinis for Grey Goose.
Give it up for Paris Hilton!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Good to see you.
-Hello.
-Nice to see you, my friend.
Alright, here's how it works.
When I say go, we're all going
to start flipping cups. Okay?
Like this. And --
Ooh, perfect.
If your cup lands upright
just like that,
you move the shot
one square forward
towards the person
across from you.
You keep going until the shot
glass crosses the red line.
If it lands on your side,
you have to do a shot.
You can choose from one of
the following --
liquid popcorn butter,
maple syrup,
or hot dog water.
-What?
-Yeah.
-We're going
to play three rounds.
I'm not going to lose this,
I'll tell you that.
Alright, when you're ready,
take your position.
I think I'm here.
-Okay.
I think I think you're here.
-Paris is -- Alright, good.
Alright, we can do this.
I don't want to make,
but we don't want --
Okay. Whew!
3, 2, 1. Here we go.
-Oh, my God. [Bleep]
♪♪
-Oh, my gosh!
Aah!
♪♪
-You got it.
-I did?
[ Buzzer ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
What?
-Sorry.
You have to pick one of these.
You had to pick one
of these to do a shooter.
-Do you have any Grey Goose?
[ Laughter ]
-We don't have
any Grey Goose out here.
And there's also a --
there's also a bucket
if you can't handle
whatever this --
-My God.
-You got to go hot dog water.
-I will literally heave.
Like, I can't even
look at that.
-I know, I can't even look
at any of them.
-Um...
Water, butter,
hot dog water,
maple -- maple syrup I guess
because it's like the sweetest.
-Yeah, maple syrup. Exactly.
That's what you got to do.
♪♪
Sorry, sorry.
-I did some of it.
-You did some of it. Okay.
Some of it counts, alright.
But it is -- just
so everyone knows --
it is maple syrup.
-It really is.
-Okay, good. Yeah. Okay.
I can't even now look
at the other two.
Alright, here we go.
I don't want to just
keep winning
because I just feel like
I'm doing really well here.
-Okay. You're talking, man,
so let's go. Let's get it.
-Yeah. Come on.
Get your heads in the game.
-Alright. Here we go. That's
round 1. Now come on, Paris.
3, 2, 1, go.
♪♪
-Yes!
-No!
♪♪
-[Bleep]
-Aah!
-Aah [bleep].
♪♪
-That's it.
It's far away from me.
♪♪
-Oh [bleep]
-Oh, yes!
♪♪
[ Buzzer ]
Aah!
♪♪
Me again?
-You again.
Liquid popcorn butter
or hot dog water,
which is water with just a t--
The New York City hot dog
is just a taste of hot dog.
-Yeah.
-You got to go butter.
-Popcorn.
-Good choice.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Don't look at it. Don't look at
it. Don't look at it.
Don't smell!
-Are you trying to give me
a heart attack?
-Don't smell it.
-I can't.
-Can't do it.
-I can't do it.
-Alright. Put it right there.
-I tried.
-That's alright. You tried.
You came close on both.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Maple syrup.
-Oh, my goodness.
-Did a little bit.
She did a little bit.
-But this is what
it comes down to.
-Yeah, that's the one.
[ Indistinct talking ]
-This is the Big Apple
right here.
-I can't even handle this.
I'm so, so not -- It's going to
be one of you three drinking.
-No, it has to be you.
-It cannot be me.
It's not going to be me.
I'm sorry. Paris. Sorry, Issa.
I'm sorry, Tariq,
but here we go.
The last round.
3, 2, 1!
♪♪
-Yes.
Yes! No.
♪♪
-Stop winning!
-What the hell?
♪♪
Oh [bleep] my God!
[ Buzzer ]
Aah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Whoo!
♪♪
-Paris.
I love you.
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That was disgusting.
My thanks to Issa Rae,
Paris Hilton, Tariq Trotter.
We're talking with Issa
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.